neither one smokes weed she drinks a
presidential campaign or a bad
installment of a a what step are you on
number four being a [ __ ] losers who
think they think they're gonna beat me
throw it yeah no way no who you think
has the greatest chance of being the
most successful runner-up to me but I
thought we would go through the tap
greatest greatest hits like done Shay by
the way yes it's a tragedy what's going
on but the most cringe-worthy hits from
the Democratic candidates and we'll have
Gavin McInnes on after this Oh so let's
just go through this to see how horrible
horrible let's see how horrible they
really honorable number what let's go
through Bernie Sanders his most
cringe-worthy moment last campaign it
would have been when he had his mic
stolen by the black that was pretty bad
if that's not allegorical for what would
happen in an anti-christian to kid
Society
I want a turkey okay the blacks gonna
take your stuff you you old Jew no no
you don't stand a Jew both chance in
hell my family no you're fine you're not
by blood but by sex yeah yeah that works
so here is Bernie shake attraction most
cringe-worthy moment here we go look he
tried to hit a punching bag okay he
keeps going for more he keeps going for
more look that old Jew has heart
okay does look at it does probably not
belongs a fighter
that's right distasteful yeah I respect
it and he never you never got him down
Everlast speed bag from Dick's prevail
that's perfect I'm just getting poem
bird for Pete but cake okay here he is
right now okay hanging out this is for
me the most cringe yeah I would never
say this is what people tell me okay
these were submitted by you you can by
the way tweet at the s Crowder because
that's the Twitter right now right now
my Twitter
he needs some followers folks yeah do
you see the costumes mr. Crowder puts on
he can dress up like a broad we get it
right right yeah yeah but he'll be
hanging out okay excuse me with a couple
of packs don't let the kids see I talk
to you it's all your new moons fly all
right mayor people to the blacks as a
gay man then committing misdemeanors
that's but it's cool don't they actually
just gave him hi-c cuz he's dead what
year old they did not they that showed
the graduation song is hi-c correct yeah
as we go dad
we remember right oh the chatter man a
head on retainer there yeah okay
different song for you guys to appeal to
the the black box okay yeah it is
shameful it's horrible
let me show you how it's done
45 it works every time Billy Dee
Williams Williams the only member of the
Old Republic they chose to dress like a
pimp
gold tassel man hey mr. Lucas I should
wear how about a cape
oh great and can I fight Bubba Fett with
a Cadillac with rolling rims spinners
that's how you would do it I love it
all right so we bet cake okay what's
with the have you seen what's with the
anger issues okay so much anger so much
hate please stick things in his mouth
could you see looking for it oh my god
driving sorry
oh my gosh because she you're
uncomfortable let's move on it's funny
though it really funny
it's wrong not only to hate but to have
a phobia of the quiz okay sure I'm not a
phobia next one I think is number two I
don't know in the election they'll all
be number two excuse me number three
okay we'll fix that in post along with
the Bulge yes I got just mustard Kamala
Harris I wish she she didn't drop out no
yes okay as of now I don't know I've
seen gang rapes more gentle than what
Tosi Gabbard did to her mm-hmm not so
raw so come a little dreams worthy
moment where she claims that she smoked
weed okay excuse me
smoked weed in college and listen to
Tupac okay at the hodgetwins to park
yeah and Snoop Dogg well doing so at the
same time here have you ever smoked okay
I did it I did it
she's so cool
look at that change smokes weed oh my
goodness oh yeah definitely snoop to pie
okay she graduated college frankly okay
truth she's that big truthful in 87 over
three years before snoop or puck had any
albums once so either she has a DeLorean
oh she was smoking
well locking up nonviolent drug
offenders in massive numbers who by the
way I've freed have done more than
9-thousand Sanders and the blacks right
I'm not one in the same minds you yeah
not more for both than any president
okay they just can't give credit no they
should the credit is due
yes we will give you credit Sarah do
well thank the pleasure is all yours yes
by the way notification Bell okay
frankly if you're subscribed because we
don't know if subscriptions work ad just
there's a new video I guess the Crowder
does he does every day yeah what time I
believe it's 8 o'clock Eastern 8 o'clock
Eastern show Elizabeth Warren
Pocahontas she tried to mate very
musically and they tell me tell me I
couldn't I couldn't do American Idol
because it's like the Olympics where
pros can not enter your welcome Kelly
Pickler yeah so would have been second
Pocahontas tried to take a chapter out
of Al she's booked by live-streaming
herself and she what she's ready for
press she really wants you to know okay
that she drinks she drinks beer she's
just like yeah hold on a sec I'm gonna
get me um a beer hop beer up here
she's new and smokes weed she drinks a
presidential campaign or a bad
installment of a a what step are you on
number four being a [ __ ] he likes it I
like I don't care thank you yep
question two the beer drinkers out there
okay how many of you drink a beer like
this look look at this clip she goes to
drink a beer oh she must have gotten
lessons on how to drink beer from Pete
but cake oh here's another one
okay she says that she prefers Netflix
and chill to Broadway dinner I have to
watch do my cribs go okay Netflix and
chill or Broadway and dinner
Oh Netflix and chill okay say it ain't
so oh my gosh I wonder if she even knows
what that means you know sure I don't
think so but she may know what it means
no no it's a tribe it's posterity
Apaches the Cherokees the Algonquin the
Iroquois and the hookers the hooker -
yeah she was chief such a good chief
with powwow town okay and this is
another one I don't quite fully
understand okay but I think audio Wade
will explain after more Pocahontas the
hits keep coming her love for some big
structure named Bailey
Carrie yeah
what are they would it what are they
cheering them it's a big structural
Bailey I think yeah I think it's the
building next door to fall on her some
stockings with her feet rolling oh yes
yeah yeah yeah that's what we call
foreshadowing Wicked Witch of the
reservation yes what half chatter but as
jokes he does thank you he has jokes
they can't joke because I don't have
that hat you don't
speaking of yin and yang we go Andrew
full cherubim yang full now I will say
that full Andrew yet full chairman he
seems pretty decent his first cherubic
oh okay
as House Democrats go nice guy but it is
pretty rough this video of him crowd
surfing at a campaign event
okay have to see this for yourself
wait wait wait let's go back and look at
yeah
he's getting the inside information on
his competition candidate who can do the
crowd surfing because he's four foot
nothing it's how we apply the goods over
let it go across the room we'll go to
chilled a because I'm contractually
obligated yes yes who do you think would
be the easiest to beat of course we
don't beat all of them but who do you
think would be hardest and easier you're
gonna beat him by a mile I think you
unfortunate two months and for two miles
sir you're right
yo Biden okay I think he's the toughest
competition you think he's the toughest
and Pete but gig is the easiest Kamala
Harris won't make it much longer so I'm
not even including her Pete but gig is
easy yeah I think that Elizabeth Warren
would probably be the easiest for you to
beat sir I think big Pete you know I
think so and then I also think I think
Bernie Sanders would probably be a
little tougher forgive me for saying so
yeah no listen
yes hard okay for now yeah poor weak
valves he's been a quarter black oh I
know it's gonna be booked no no I guess
I'm gonna say Joe Biden is gonna be a
hardest and Elizabeth Warren the easiest
okay okay okay machine we're getting
what we call could said sis mmm I'm
still I think I'm still right though sir
yeah yeah you would no way next day
shipping bishop still waiting I think
that you would beat chief lip-lock beer
first be the easiest for you thank you
thanks
I think I think the hardest for you to
play him it would be my cousin he looks
exactly like both of them Andrew yang
you people copulate like rabbits we do
we're taking over yes I would have said
wretch but you people eat them as a gift
for the people I'll give you the secret
code for our restaurants so no dog meat
when I go to the Chinese restaurant I
just ordered the Splinter I got that
reference we do have to go to Gavin
McInnes but I will say this of all of
these people folks listen look for this
right now in this in this election we
have the best academy that we've had in
modern American history like its lowest
unemployment we have highest labor force
participation rate we have a job surplus
okay that micro himself couldn't fail
more black businesses being started
Louis black unemployment rate okay crime
is at an all-time low
$5,000 median household income increase
it used to be about the economy stupid
but now you will see whichever candidate
this is talk about anything but the
Academy grad known that talk about the
Academy because I'm stupid and we will
put that on a bumper sticker for them
okay if you like this video then
subscribe by clicking wherever it says
subscribe and hit the notification bail
because subscriptions don't always work
here on YouTube and I'm going to have an
investigation on that but most
importantly checking every day new
videos at you and mug club okay it's a
good club folks it's the best club and
that's what allows this cut debt to stay
on youtube because they're not big feds